sigamos haciendo algunos problemas que
nos ayuden a identificarnos muy bien con
la ecuación de las ideal
dv nr t así que tenemos 98 mililitros de
un gas desconocido misterioso que pesa o
mejor dicho cuya masa es punto 0 81
gramos no es peso porque el peso está
dado en newtons y estos son gramos
corresponde a masa a condiciones
normales de presión y temperatura
calculé la masa molar del gas entonces
nos piden calcular la masa por mol
massa
mulay
o más a formol ahora podríamos solo
sustituir en la ecuación p
la nrc sabemos cuáles son las
condiciones normales de presión y
temperatura temperatura es 273 kelvin y
la presión a condiciones normales es de
una atmósfera una atmósfera y claro
sabemos que el volumen es de 98
mililitros
entonces simplemente podemos despejar
para saber cuántos moles tenemos ya lo
hemos hecho antes pero la otra forma de
resolverlo es que a condiciones normales
de presión y temperatura un gas ideal
hace dos vídeos hicimos un problema
donde un molde de gas ideal a
condiciones normales de presión y
temperatura requiere un volumen de 22.4
litros y no soy muy buena para memorizar
cosas pero esto es algo que es bueno
recordar si queremos pasar un examen de
química siempre podemos recurrir a esto
si el problema está a las condiciones
normales pues al saber que un mol
requiere este volumen si un molde
necesita 22.4 litros cuantos moles
llamémosle x moles
porque no los conocemos hay en 98
mililitros es decir punto 0 98 litros
establecida esta ecuación proporcional
podemos calcular los moles que buscamos
en ambos casos es un gas ideal a las
mismas condiciones
podemos decir que 22.4 x x es igual a
punto 0 98 nos queda que x es igual a
punto 0 98 / 22.4 y esto está en moles
verdad entonces punto 0 98
/
y 22.4
es igual a punto 0 043 75 moles punto 0
043 75 moles el problema nos dice que
que este gas tiene una masa de punto 0
81 gramos verdad pero cuántos gramos hay
por mol
tenemos punto 0 81 gramos
y simplemente los dividimos entre punto
0 043 75 moles
esto es igual a usemos la calculadora
tenemos punto 0 81 en 3.00 43 75 es
igual a 18.51 esto es igual a 18.5
gramos
gramos por mod
ahora les tengo una pregunta interesante
ya que descubrimos la masa molar de
nuestra sustancia misteriosa con 98
mililitros y una masa de punto 0 81
gramos a condiciones normales de presión
y temperatura tienen alguna idea de a
qué sustancia le corresponden 18.5
gramos
quizás no sea exacto pero a mi parecer
un buen candidato es el agua agua es h2o
lo escribiré en azul que le queda mejor
h2o la masa de cada hidrógeno es 1
recuerden el hidrógeno no tiene
neutrones en su estado basal solo un
protón y un electrón así que son más a
molar es de un gramo y el oxígeno tiene
una masa de 16 gramos como son dos
hidrógenos 2 + 16 es igual a 18 parece
que nuestra sustancia misteriosa es agua